yeah it's always some [__] like that
dude and then I got home and my whole
place smelled like
[Music]
[__] welcome back to careful boys where
we are afraid of everything always
afraid speaking of being afraid oh my
God what do you
fear everyone
everyone see you guys next time that's
[Music]
it what are you afraid of despite having
maybe perhaps no reason to but weal we
are everybody I'm afraid of a lot of
things I think a lot of fear around here
my number one fear after becoming a
parent is uh taica passing before me oo
you know that'd be like cuz even one
time he mentioned he was like uh he was
talking about
um he was like hey hey papa like one day
I'm going to have a kid and then you're
going to be a grandpa and then you're
going to pass away and then I'm going to
be a grandpa too huh and then even that
thought of him being a grandpa and
passing away like made me sad I was like
dude one day he is going to die and
obviously I know I'm going to die and I
know he's going to die but when thinking
about him that way I was like dude one
day he is going to die that's [__]
crazy that's tight sad episode you yeah
thanks for that bro damn do you ever
think about how we we kind of will live
forever at least until they probably
take all our videos down for being
offensive
content yeah we're Immortal right in a
way but if we go through nuclear war and
then Google gets hit yeah all the
servers get taken out yeah but if they
store it using blockchain technology in
The Ether hello in the cloud that'll be
wonderful that's all decentralized yeah
that's the only thing I think I'm really
afraid of everything else I feel like we
could always come back from wow that's
the only thing huh that is a big thing
though yeah to outlive your kid isn't
that like whateverand want a miracle I
feel like Financial stuff whatever like
you could always build back up you know
there's
always I thought I missed something no
he said I was like damn to outlive your
kid he's like yeah it's what every
parent
wants [__] stupid continue I'm sorry
obious dang who's afraid of what are you
guys' biggest fears what are you guys
biggest fearce damn that's crazy I mean
I've always been afraid of Deep Dark
Water like being like really under under
the ocean right but you went scuba
diving I'm I'm a certified scuba diver
indeed buted I only um and trained for
50 ft I'm trained for 50 ft oh okay so
like that's not deep dark water that's
not the real [__] is is being afraid of
like skydiving scuba diving like all the
extreme sports the same thing as just
not wanting to participate in any of
these things just because you don't want
to is interesting I think about the same
me I'm asking myself am I afraid of
jumping out of a plane it's like or does
it to like I just don't want to do it
but why am I actually afraid of it or am
I denying is that like yeah you're a
[__]
boy if you're not afraid of jumping out
of a plane I think you're weird I think
everyone's afraid to jump that's what
I'm saying that's why but to me that's
default I know that there's like default
yeah it's like I know what the point is
of skydiving I know why people do these
extreme things and it does if it doesn't
appeal to me doesn't mean I'm afraid of
it you know that's that's why it's like
power slap it's like I'm not I don't
feel like doing it exactly like why
would I want to get slapped in the face
doesn't interest I definitely don't want
to get power yeah I don't want to get
hit in the face but if we're talking
about like [__] that I'm afraid of dude
there's like this weird icky feeling I
get about dead birds did I already talk
about this dead bird dead bird yeah
alive birds not as afraid but dude as
soon as like I see feathers and blood
and like I'm like how many dead birds
you see and then you see blood on your
hands it who yeah weirdo so you don't
like fried chicken no not not food in
the context of food it's fine but when I
I see it like dead when you go to the
Chinese barbecue they got hanging ass
dead birds oh you can't see that either
no that's fine oh in the context of food
but like let's say it was just a bird
that just [__] hit a window and I'm
like oh that's [__] scary to me it's
like it's like Omen no yeah yeah that's
that's cuz it seems like they just died
for no reason but maybe it could have
been sick or but sometimes Birds be
tripping dude they be running into
things all the yeah sometimes I see
birds on a car Grill and I'm like how
dude you know what I saw one time on the
freeway of like a pigeon going into the
road and Landing probably cuz it was
tired from flying and then a car just
going whoop and then just starts going
like this this is what you see and
Feathers going like I'm like oh that's
kind of that's a stupid place to park
bro creeps me out dude I was CH nature I
was just chilling at home right heard a
loud bang loud bang and then I'm like
all right well go look around okay
nobody's here whatever the next day I I
I'm awoken to Nikki screaming and I'm
like okay she found whatever the [__]
that was and of course there's a dead
bird like on the ground so it hit the
window snapped it neck or something yeah
killed
itself see that's so I like see now
we're going to be seeing dead bir the
weird thing is I've seen other dead
animals and it doesn't creep me out as
much as Birds specifically I don't maybe
because it turns you on wa
dude Laden sexual yeah why don't you put
on a bird suit we'll
find go let's
go that was good let's go to Second City
wow that's not the iasa can that's the
Ecstasy
can go can you know I'm afraid of of um
of being accused of a crime and I don't
have an alibi o that's really good scary
getting framed yeah or just like or just
you can't like you're being interrogated
and you have no good answers even if you
didn't like and you're in and you're
innocent yeah because you know you're
only you're only like you know as
innocent as you can prove but then like
if they're asking you like where were
you on this date I'm like I'm pretty bad
at knowing what I was doing on a
specific date I have to like look it up
so I try to keep theth bro yeah I know
that's why it's important to keep it's
weird if you don't have enough like
stuff to back up that you weren't there
at that time and do you know you know
what I would do to cuz I'm a TV jury I
would hear you say like I don't know
where I was and I like yeah yeah yeah
yeah sure get him yeah guilty get him
fry them where do you think that came
from did were you like framed really bad
as a kid and that like created like this
deep like Fe no I don't I don't think
I've ever I've never been falsely
accused of anything really other than
like stupid little things but then I
think um it's the power of like just not
you know like when you're not guilty but
you're being asked and you're nervous so
you sound guilty it's that it's like
when you didn't do it but I wonder if I
sound guilty just because I'm being
asked for you know I just I hate the
idea of like everything I've been
convicted of I I did it I definitely did
it like it was me but then I think
because I've done things I always wonder
like oh if it comes to a point where I
didn't do it do I have a clean enough
like out wow cuz people have to think of
that too you know like you you could
have you know I think when you're not
thinking at all is kind of uh dangerous
too when you're innocent like the movie
of The Fugitive right well that's
different cuz his wife [__] said his
name on her last dying breath but did he
not do it though he didn't do it though
right the one our man did it yeah yeah
one man yeah he didn't do it but I think
that for some reason it is an irrational
fear but then when when you see examples
of like dudes who really didn't do it
yeah and then they go to jail for like
20 years or some [__] yeah but these
aren't the guys I'm not talking about
the dude that was there but his friend
did it I'm talking about dudes that
weren't even [__] there oh had
nothing to do with it yeah yeah
yeah that's pretty rough like hard come
back from yeah but the chances of it
happening is very low too I think yeah
it's very low but then why is you
afraid yeah why you tripping up Ste
that's what you
said I'm just saying cuz that doesn't
happen often give me one let's go dude
two for two Ken let's go he's on fire
right now K is roasting back yeah man
that's pretty scary it is scary to think
something that kind of scared me
thinking about that was like
being like like in trouble in a foreign
country cuz you know I travel a lot and
then like I was like dude yeah like okay
I imagined you on the stand and like
having to defend yourself and I'm like
when will I ever be in a situation like
that and I was like well what if like I
was just like in a different country
don't know the language and then the
corrup police there like lock me up I
don't have any way to contact anybody
and I'm just like what the [__] like
what do I do yeah the worst part is they
you don't know what the [__] they're
saying about you like dang that sucks
I'm like in Mexico and [__] and then
they throw me up in like a place and
this my inmate like my cell mate's
name's Pedro and he's like I like your
hair yeah doesn't sound that bad I'm
like [__] dude I don't know man you're
queer baiting I don't know what to do
you
know or like that's when you go crazy
you're like they call me the gay
vampire you go yeah you go nuts you got
to [__] wild out a little
bit I don't know who I don't want to be
with the game why do they call him that
I don't want to find out I'mma suck your
blood out of your
dick the blood out of your
dick you just got to go out go for it my
friend told me when he first moved to
Vietnam like in
2009 right it was still like not
Foreigner friendly but he's he's he's
Vietnamese but he had American passport
and he he just kept going there to work
work in the media out there and one day
he got in the cab and as soon as he got
in the cab two secret police guys also
got in the cab sat next to him and said
you've been coming to Vietnam a lot what
are you doing out here W I hate those
people dude and that's [__] crazy and
then he was just talking you know it's
like Vietnamese secret police he's like
no man I didn't say you I don't think
you see me but now I see you and we see
each other
and so he was asking him hella questions
he said that even though he wasn't
guilty like it was scary as [__] right
[__] yeah cuz he's just like oh [__]
what's going on but like it's not likely
to mean anything doing anything so yeah
chances of that happening doesn't happen
so why you worried about it it's a funny
ass thing to point out every time every
damn but statistically I mean dude if it
was like uh one of those foreign
countries you just give them money you
know what'll be scary is um you just you
just grease them yeah well then they
accuse you of bribery and then no they
like oh then and then they go oh yeah go
ahead that that usually happens what if
that's what they want you to do what if
it's a [__] they go like this they go
give me $100 oh I only have one eye give
me another 100 I don't see
anything exactly but it's like $1 bill
and [__] he that from something cuz
that's really
funny should have done 50s man it's like
d it would have been 100 oh yeah yeah
yeah that's true you know what's a scary
thought is um being caught with your
pants down like you've been oh [__] just
like literally no like just in general
like like you've been targeted you
didn't see it coming someone was
plotting something against you you got
got and you got got and you're just like
[__] man that's I guess it depends on
the severity of it dude Joe's a [__]
Crime Boss
Dog dude the way he says that I'm like
dude you're a [__] crime no the real
Crime Boss is that guy right there so so
so last night well thought out we're at
the JK like Po party right and he's like
hey uh I'll see you day tomorrow I'm
like yeah I'll see day tomorrow and he's
like got some surprises for you and I'm
like dude I'm like dude talk about can't
sleep when it comes to Ryan and
surprises I'm like okay what the [__]
could he possibly do for real like game
I like game planning scenarios I'm like
okay so like he gets a marching band to
come he probably has connections to get
a marching B I don't have that kind of
budget he knows a lot of trumpet players
yeah I'm like what's he going to do he
knows a lot of musical people so he's
going to have like a [__] dance team
come in here to really kill me a step
team yeah and then they come and dance
all around us or some [__] and then of
course he's going to [__] with all Steve
with a bunch of dancers which is the
thing I hate the most yeah so I'm like
I'm game gameing scenario freaking the
[__] out bro I can't walk out of the
bathroom without worrying this guy's
going to prank me you know what I'm
talking about person you're talking
about hell week when we were we walking
out of the bathroom wondering is there
going to be a bunch of blocks in the
door yeah yeah looking for Charlie
everywhere I go dude when I come out the
[__] those kinds of pranks are now
built into the wall bro that's why you
put the [__] mirror there dude very
scary stuff do you guys have the the the
normal irrational fears like fear of
flying fear of heights fear of drowning
like you know like those fears that are
like they're supposed to be irrational
but it's to me it's not that irrational
cuz it makes sense and a lot of people
have it yeah but like I think I have the
opposite of that where it's like those
normal things that I should be scared of
I'm not like getting into your car going
to work that's a [__] you have a way
higher chance of like [__] no like
like flying a lot of people are afraid
of flying right but for me I find real
comfort in flying like that's when I can
actually relax and go to it's safer it's
weird because I think more than I have a
fear of dying I have a higher fear of my
decision causing someone else to die un
un like wrongfully o like if I was like
I don't have a fear of drowning but I
have a fear of telling someone yeah you
can go out there and swim it's fine and
then they and the shark comes and you
know what I mean like that's that's
worse to me that's heavy but it's also
not your fault if something were to
happen to that person right like should
have known how to swim better yeah you
know what can thanks man you're right I
try to make it feel better yeah yeah no
yeah it's but that's what it is it's
like it's the feeling of struggling
about whether or not it's your fault oh
the guilt it's it's the back and forth I
think that's like it's so much easier
when something's absolute he died I died
you know but then when it's like did I
cause it my fault is oh cuz this action
led to that yeah yeah I've been thinking
about for me recently this is kind of
[__] sad but I've been thinking about
more of
uh losing somebody in your life that
you're really close to like that [__]
gets me every single time I'm sure it
gets everybody but you know I've been
thinking about that a lot more where I'm
like I don't know how I would react if I
lost something that was really close to
me and that scares me like that well you
don't know how you're going to take it I
don't know like you never had anyone
close to you not not really like super
close to it's painful no of course like
when I think about like my mom spoiler
or like my dad yeah it sucks like it
sucks very painful everybody that's lost
somebody's all happy and smiley yeah but
like like thinking about not [__]
Rosie dude no for sure you know what I
mean and I think about that a lot and I
go [__] sometimes dude what if it makes
you
funer dude two months ago I'm coming
home from JK and like it's like normal
day normal night I'm home I'm landed I
text Nikki I'm landed and then like no
response I'm like whatever and I get
outside and then I call her goes WR the
voice and then I call her again goes WR
The Voice goes WR the voice and I'm like
okay it's now been 30 minutes since I
landed no word from Nikki straight the
voice and then my legs turned to jelly I
start to like [__] like I'm in shock
at this point I'm not even thinking
rationally I think I'm like I think
everyone thinks I'm an [__] cuz I
keep on just wandering and like people
are like walking around me like what the
[__] is with this guy and then I'm just
like I don't know what to do so then um
I was just like oh my God like oh my God
please God don't take her from me please
don't take her from me that's hard man
yeah and it it was like it was like the
most dramatic [__] right cuz you're just
like there you're in your head spiraling
yeah spiraling she was in the middle of
a really mean poker hand that's
it $25,000 pot so then I was like okay I
was like okay I'm I'm call my neighbor I
call my neighbor and I'm going to be
like Yo dude you [__] go ring my
doorbell go ring my doorbell right and
then he's not picking up cuz he's
getting [__] high or whatever he's
chilling get [__] high he well he he
end up picking he's like Yo dude I'm
pretty fued up what's going
on I was like I was like you need to go
to my house right now you need to
[__] ring the doorbell but but about
what I was trying to get a hold of him
it was going to voice for him too or not
going to it was just leaving me ringing
or whatever I went to our security
system that I have via my phone and I
just started to turn it on and turn it
off and turn it on and turn it off and
turn it on and turn off Smart yeah so
that cuz when you do that she the [__]
talks to my house and like and she's
like she's like uh uh security set down
activated security system deactivated
security system activated and then I
finally when I'm on the phone my
neighbor I'm like yo you need to go spam
the [__] doorbell Nikki calls me and
she's like she's like my phone died I'm
calling you from my laptop right now now
I fell asleep downstairs I'm okay and I
was
like dude it's always I fell
asleep it's always some [__] like that
dude and then I got home and my whole
place smelled like
[__] that bleachy bleachy but that's
normal but that's normal that bleachy
bleach I was like it really smells like
coming here and she's like oh yeah
didn't you come in here a couple days
ago and I was like that's true that's
what it was gave be mad because it was
like y that's true suppress my feelings
suppress my feelings that that is the
hardest oh man I was dead you get to
that
placeo I just kept on saying please God
don't take her from me please don't take
her from me yeah talk about don't you
don't want to lose taica first [__] dude
if I lost Nikki man oh my lordy Lord I
used to think about that too when like
when I would just think about like if
something happened to smack I would the
first thing that my mind goes is like
but man she has like she had has so much
potential like did I [__] it up by her
running into me and changing the course
of her Destiny you know what I mean like
is it was my element of presence the
reason why like things went bad like I
would just she probably had like 300
more of those smash tick talk videos
dance ready to go dude chicken dances
it's like when you know when you know
your girl is so good it's like you you
can't help but feel like damn like you
want her to them to live out the the
best that they could possibly get to one
of one and if anything happened on your
watch going based off what Steve was
saying like me and Joel like be in bed
and I'm like like who Do You Love More
you left me more you left taica yeah and
she'll ask me the same thing and both of
our answers is taica like
TI we're on the right team like Tao way
more but that's how it's supposed to be
right yeah yeah yeah that's so cool
that's [__] hilarious it's cuz he's
the new addition he's the new fun one
but what D if you had two kids how do
you answer that
I think for sure you have your favorite
I you'll have your favorite yeah so if
someone's cooler than taica then for
sure it'll be the other one dang you
hear that he's just cooler what do you
want he's just cooler look at him he
wears sunglasses wherever he goes was
Gio the favorite in her family among her
siblings no not until not until now oh
so she moved up I think as a kid um like
that they're that recent immigrant
family so it's just like okay like who
who can like stay keep this order and
then Jill was always the rebellious one
like why why why right and then everyone
that was kind of like not so rebellious
like okay cool I'll follow the path and
then now I think her rebelliousness and
curiosity like allowed her to be who she
is and then so now she became like the
most successful one and now is like the
pillar of the family
oh so now it's like now she is cuz now
like if her mom has any like really big
things that need ch help with or what
she can count on Gio to like handle like
her future will or handle the house or
whatever you know wow she she's wearing
the pants that's really tight yeah like
when G's dad passed away like she came
in and took care of like the the funeral
like just handled all the like
proceedings and all that stuff while
people were still mourning they didn't
know what to do like she was just like
the levelheaded one when did she process
it she says she still doesn't know if
she fully has yet she could still like
one day she could just probably just
break down you know what's like out of
curiosity besides obviously like Tao
passing away which is the saddest thing
what's another fear of something
happening to him that's not fatal like a
massive one he becomes a leftist woki
yeah honestly if you become some spoiled
ass little entitled [__] I'd be like
[__] that's it just [__] I'm like
[__] [__] cuz I was in my control and
i f it up somehow but you just blame
yourself yeah he's like Dad can I be
Gavin Newsome for
Halloween I [__] ruined
you I [__] up I ruined
him